the question of who rules america has
been debated throughout america's own
history it was originally raised and
answered to some degree by the american
revolution in the 1770s
that fought for independence from the
british crown so that americans at least
some americans could rule themselves or
at least they hoped they could
we're at columbia university
with dr eric foner a historian and
writer
and teacher here at the university for a
long time period of time
i think what is unusual today is two
things one
the degree of inequality
never before has the very very top the
one percent had so much of the national
income and wealth in its own hands and
uh you know so that the gap is greater
than ever before and secondly um
you know occupy wall street is not
primarily a movement of farmers of
laborers it doesn't have the same base
people need to learn history that's part
of our job to know that this issue has
been around for a long time
there is nothing un-american about
raising the question of economic
plutocracy economic inequality it's as
american as apple pie and um
you know i think that the occupy wall
street people are
you know legitimate heirs of a long and
venerable tradition in this country
today the activists of occupy wall
street are continuing the fight for
independence and economic justice from
domination by a small elite in the name
of the majority the 99
of america
i do think what's been brilliant about
the occupy wall street movement is the
framing of the one percent person is 99
and i think i think
i think what we basically have is an
undemocratic power structure that goes
across
political economic social and cultural
lines
what kind of impact has occupy wall
street had in raising basic questions
about the nature of power in america we
asked sociologist stanley aranowitz
it's had pers it has impact on
perception
it has changed the conversation
the question
is whether or not it will be able to
change policy and the argument that i
would make is that it should not worry
about changing policy in the short run
the only way to change policy in the
long run is going to be to create even a
bigger movement and in order to create
that bigger movement what it has to do
is has to ask the question what kind of
a life do we want to lead what is the
good life what is the vision of the way
in which we want to live david degraw
coined the 99 percent 1
phrase and was an early occupy organizer
he explained why who rules america
remains an urgent issue
so you have big banks and concentrated
wealth that's just rigged the political
process
uh you know investigating it we have a
country where
u.s millionaire households have 46
trillion dollars of wealth it's just a
mind-boggling number so you know over
the past generation all the wealth has
gone to the top you know really it's one
tenth of one percent more than one
percent but uh you know breaking it down
even further you have 400 people who
have as much wealth as 155 million
americans so that's 400 people as much
wealth as half the population
the seeds of a battle that many of the
occupiers see as a new american
revolution is not really new but deeply
rooted in the unresolved history of
conflict in the united states between
those who own and control its resources
and those who want economic equality
so the question is who rules america
and that's a funny
question because then you talk about
power
the first thing you have to understand
is america is a business venture like
stolen land stolen stolen property
capitalism is about making money
you know
many revolutions start at the top in
other words the people who began the
struggle against great britain were
merchants in boston and new york
plantation owners in virginia you know
most of the founders in virginia are
slave owners
but what happens is as the struggle
intensifies they have to
generate support among ordinary people
and when you do that you break open the
political system and you open the door
for very very different kinds of demands
slaves start demanding their own freedom
uh women native americans start
demanding greater equality so what
happens at the beginning when a you know
a more privileged class begins the
resistance
that doesn't necessarily tell you how
the whole process is going to take place
this conflict between the one percent
actually the 0.001
and the 99 had its echoes here in the
home of america's anti-colonial uprising
in the back streets of boston where a
freedom trail today commemorates a
massacre by the british and a fight for
liberty and that's where we'll take you
next
was the american revolution really a
revolution the british thought it was a
revolution no question about that it was
not a social upheaval in the way let us
say the french revolution was
but it certainly overthrew an entire
system of government
it replaced the
ruling class with another one so that
seems to be what a revolution is about
and it raised these questions of
equality in the society not not just
equality in terms of one percent and 99
percent but the role of slavery in
american life the status of women in
american life it unleashed a kind of um
struggle for equality among all sorts of
groups which continued long after the
revolution was over
listen my children and you shall hear of
the midnight ride of paul revere that's
one of the most famous poems of the
american revolution and here we are in
front of the statue of paul revere the
man who alerted all of massachusetts to
the british troops coming into their
communities
we're on the freedom trail in boston
where the american revolution is
remembered what kind of a revolution was
it what actually happened here in boston
back in the 1700s what have we learned
since then
thousands of tourists and students visit
these revolutionary monuments every day
but most have only a foggy idea of what
really happened and tend to repeat the
mythologies that are taught in their
schools here was paul revere
paul revere
was one of the great revolutionary
heroes are you kids here to see the
special call of the year yes we are
can i ask you a question about it sure
we're doing a little tv program here
who was paul revere what was this all
about do you know he was a founder
yeah one night ride to warn about the
british for coming did you know that he
was a very rich businessman a
silversmith here in boston and that he
wanted to be in the continental army and
they wouldn't let him in did you know
that he didn't know that i know that did
you know that in boston there was this
merchant class you know business leaders
the one percent who were really running
the whole show uh in many ways and that
the people were not as involved because
back then there was slaves
there were indentured servants uh there
were a lot of people who didn't have a
say in what was going on did you know
about that no idea i didn't know
anything about paul revere
we would love to live
my brother bill here has taught history
uh to students in massachusetts for many
many many years and has followed you
know the various debates about our
history what was it about this
revolution uh you know was it a popular
uprising or wasn't sort of led by elites
here in boston well both were true they
were popular elements uh ordinary people
did resent the british
ordinary people did participate in riots
and boycotts
but there was a one percent back then
the leaders of the revolution
both led it and channeled it
they were certainly not above using
words like liberty and freedom uh to
deflect and distract people from their
own discontents
in the colonies and their own interests
i mean the the
business class of boston
didn't want more taxes on their products
they wanted to compete with the british
goods they felt they shouldn't be taxed
and as a result there was a t original
tea party here in boston
and there were
you know merchants like uh john hancock
who was into smuggling goods and you're
right they didn't want to pay british
taxes i mean there were other factors
behind the revolution as well but when
this revolution was codified
in 1787 at the constitutional convention
the people who were invited were the
large landowners the slave owners the
merchant class
no women no indians no blacks no working
people actually there were slaves that
were inspired by the revolution to try
to get their freedom some actually i
think the idea of the revolution and the
idea of democracy
uh were radical inspiring revolutionary
in ways that that actually might have
made the leaders uncomfortable since
some of them
themselves own slaves uh they they
really didn't want this to go viral in
the way it it did around the world so
who ruled america then
in a way their grandchildren
are ruling it today and sometimes direct
descendants
of those people
so uh you know i mean there was a
certain amount of class mobility uh
indentured servitude disintegrated due
to the chaos of the revolution but i
don't think the people who led the
revolution really intended a social
revolution that was really not
what they were thinking about
after the revolution people like daniel
shays in western massachusetts a farmer
a captain in the revolution
did try to
inspire organize another rebellion
against those who he saw as replacing
his british masters
this time they were the colonial leaders
[Music]
[Music]
so here we are
225 years after the shays rebellion
rocked western massachusetts in a
challenge to the one percent of those
times we have a memorial for daniel
shays and the men who fought with him
and what's interesting is we have
american flags being put in a sense
almost at his tombstone here
marking support for the values and the
aspirations that he fought for
[Music]
my name is dave walstein
you're at the stagecoach tavern in
western massachusetts town of sheffield
and this painting is a painting of
daniel shea's militiamen
daniel shays fought in the revolution
they came back from the revolution and
found
their farms being foreclosed and many
put in prison because of the same debt
crisis that we're
experiencing
now
there are many similarities but
essentially
one of the promises of the revolution
was to annul the foreign debt
and the farmers came home and discovered
the debt was even greater and the banks
were even tougher
today the shay's rebellion is mostly
forgotten but it lives on on youtube
with songs and dramatic recreations
shays now unsheathed his sword and
ordered the fife and drum players to
strike a platoon
the men began marching in cadence the
irony says historian eric foner is that
shays was just a front man for a mass
movement
in fact it was the opponents who said
it's chase's rebellion in order to find
the kind of boogeyman you know they can
attack
so let's forget about shays as a person
and think about the mass movement the
farmers the ordinary laborers who took
to the streets shut down the courts
and said wait a minute we had a
revolution
we have installed a government that's
supposed to represent the people here in
massachusetts and yet it's talking you
know it's the bankers and the landowners
and the merchants who are getting the
benefit of everything
it was the first occupy wall street
movement
they petitioned
the government in boston for redress
and the government ignored the petitions
and they're having still had their arms
they went to these court sites and
picketed to prevent the courts from
sitting
succeeded to some extent
until private militias were formed and
the massachusetts militias were formed
to suppress it
it was suppressed right near here right
last battle
was fought in sheffield
it was led by brigadier ashley
who's the ashley house is still here
and colonel ashley his
parents were one of the heroes of
revolution so here we have the same
family
building independence but then
trying to suppress it
if many white americans were
disappointed by the achievements of the
american revolution what about blacks
and native americans
in 1730 when sheffield was incorporated
there were 30 black families in
sheffield half were slaves half were
free but the famous story is again at
the ashley house one of the servants
elizabeth freeman called ma betts
overheard all the talk about the
massachusetts declaration of
independence at the dining table
and it occurred to her that may she
might qualify and she actually filed in
the court of great barrington and won
her freedom so here you have the court
giving freedom on one hand and
suppressing freedom on the other
years later a small black community in
the area that daniel shays made famous
became the home of a young man who had
become a leader of the fight for civil
rights he coupled concerns for racial
equality with demands for economic
justice today in the center of his
hometown of great barrington
massachusetts there's a wall mural
celebrating his political and
intellectual contributions it includes
quotes from president barack obama and
martin luther king dr w.e.b du bois
du bois was one of the
titan giants of the 20th century of
course he's born in the 19th century du
bois put forward the issues which are
still with us the race issue in america
you know he said 1903 the problem of the
20th century is the problem of the color
line it's still a problem in this
country and around the world du bois
talked about economic equality and how
to gain that and he grappled with these
questions he's a brilliant writer a
brilliant thinker and much of what he
said is still relevant i think to
thinking about american society
what about native americans
they were the ones
to be eliminated
because it was their land that was
wanted not even their labor roxanne
dunbar ortiz is part of america's
indigenous movements and says the people
we call indians were being exterminated
we asked her about the american
revolution it wasn't a revolution it was
a war of independence
from the you know the colonial
power
but it wasn't an anti-colonial
revolution like the bolivarian
revolutions in south america or the
asian revolution
so there are many different even
competing narratives about the origins
of the united states the united states
of course was founded as a settler state
as a colonial estate became an
imperialist power
and
the democracy has always been
an oligarchy
you know a capitalist democracy with a
rhetoric of
populism
which is so strongly based on race that
is if you're not if you're not black
you're not a slave
you're not indigenous if you're white
and a settler then
everyone could be a king everyone can
own land
and be a landlord so all these peasants
who came as settlers
the dream is to be
you know
be the king of the hills
and
so it's a very um
very insidious kind of democracy because
it's a it's a an illusion
illusion or not this is a subject that
needs to be examined if we are to
understand who rules america the origins
of the one percent and then teach about
it
so this is all part of the history that
most americans probably don't know did
you find when you were teaching students
here that many of them just didn't know
much about their own history
i think there are many students that i
taught
uh in one of the towns that fought at
concord
who were never
even in the spot we're standing in now
i think that that's true that that many
kids were not familiar with that history
beyond local battlefields and so on the
other thing about the revolutionary war
which is relevant to today because we
live in a globalized world is that this
revolution started locally here in
boston but soon the british were
involved the dutch the french it became
a war of many different countries all
fighting on american soil well very true
and the the french intervention was was
very critical to our success it wasn't
all through the force and valor of our
eyes
uh there were other people involved but
i think the you know the idea itself has
played a revolutionary role in history
but the idea itself
did not create a deep social revolution
in the united states and to this day
people are distracted
by
words like liberty and freedom and
justice
in the same way that they were back then
ironically the original tea party which
inspired the modern right-wing tea party
movement today was actually a protest
against an earlier form of corporate
imperialism
why was t the issue not corn or whiskey
or something like that it was because
the east india company had gone bankrupt
in china
and the crown the british crown bail
them out
so they wouldn't you know lose their
lose their assets but then the crown
looked around said well what does the
company have that we can sell well it
turned out what they had was tea so they
decided to market the tea and that's why
it was t that was
uh the taxed issue
so here you have a big financial failure
and the
it was global the the
the implications
trip rippled across the pacific rippled
across the atlantic and we have the
boston tea party
throughout our history there have been
sort of conspiracy theories about all of
this i mean today for example both the
right and the left seems to see the
federal reserve bank as sort of a
conspiracy concocted in 1913
without any proper process and kind of
running the show
yeah well you know conspiracy theories
conspiracy thinking is deeply embedded
in our political culture my
ph.d supervisor my mentor richard
hofstetter wrote the famous book in the
1960s the paranoid style in american
politics in which he traced out various
kinds of conspiracarial thinking uh
whether it was catholics who were in the
before the civil war trying to undermine
america or uh you know various other
groups at various times immigrants
others trying to you know destroy the
american culture or
the trilateral commission remember them
in the 1970s were supposedly ruling the
whole world
now the federal reserve right if we only
abolish the federal reserve bank
everything would go back to some utopia
of the past
throughout us history you see various
right-wing movements
point out scapegoats in the society and
they're usually the the folks who are
already marginalized in some way or
another and and what happens is that
there comes a moment when it becomes
really useful for the elite powers
whether they're in government or
corporations to encourage these
movements so you get a tea party or you
get a militia movement like in the 90s
or you get the ku klux klan in the
1800's and what this is all about is
taking angry mostly white people who are
mostly somewhat privileged and
convincing them that they're about to
fall down the social economic ladder
i guess the basic problem with
conspiracy theories is that
no group can fully determine what
happens even people with great power
launch things and then they kind of lose
control of them and things happen in a
way that is unpredictable
when you look back at history and and
you maybe can see because of you know
it's a long time ago all of these forces
yet today somehow in the news we never
see these forces what we see are
politicians spouting various you know
rhetoric and speeches but we don't
really know whose interests they're
serving who's behind the scenes well
this is why we need research we need uh
we need an understanding of who rules
america
because the mythology today is that it
is the people who rule america
and
most folks don't know
a great deal
in terms of specifics about the role
that corporations play
um
the way
politicians are tied to corporate
interests
change is possible i think when one
talks about who rules america and a
power elite one should not use that to
simply fall into a kind of quietism and
say well nothing is possible no change
is possible everything's under control
many of the major popular movements in
our history have been big surprises you
know nobody expected them to come and i
think the same thing with occupy wall
street nobody expected occupy wall
street to come up similarly simply out
of nowhere and so i think you know we
have seen that over and over again in
our history and we will continue to
people say the one percent you know we
are 99
but you know when i broke down the
numbers it was really it is a couple
hundred people in this country that have
immense wealth if you look at the if you
look at our election process it's
something like uh you know one hundredth
of one percent accounts for something
like eighty percent of the campaign
finance i mean that's insanity i mean
it's completely it's a rigged game
and now the ball of history has been
passed to a new generation fighting to
transform a large and complex country
with many power centers but just as in
the past it has determined minorities
who make the difference an elite made
the american revolution and as we will
see a power elite still rules
coming up in the next episode of who
rules america how the military and the
corporations took over
the people who rule america are
the large corporate
entities which are supernatural they
have no loyalty to the nation state
next time on who rules america
you